calling in right now as the general
manager of the minnesota vikings kind
enough to take a
time out of his monday uh is none other
than rick spielman how are you rick
thanks thanks for having me on we're
actually i'm sitting in the middle of
our combine meetings getting ready for
next year's draft is that right
never end wow you're already you're
already locked in on that huh rick no
kidding that's uh that's quite something
well look i hate to spoil your mood but
i just heard that uh
uh shannon sharp plans to call one of
your players on his show tomorrow
so um i hope i don't know if you if you
heard any of that conversation to julio
jones on on today's uh
fox sports world has that cracked your
world that is not great boy
all right that's what we call a white
house i have not heard it you'll get
you'll get that joke later on when you
hang up the phone and you'll find
out you ask your staff what's going on
with julio jones you'll find that out
um so uh let's talk about your people
doing something it's hayden making a
trade
no i think i'm making a trade with leo
jones i didn't know about no
i have no idea man but uh it is it is um
something that is uh in the ether right
now i've got an interesting question for
you
what is it like uh to be in the same
division building a team
as your brother what's that like rick
well my brother's got a little different
role than i do
but you know we still communicate almost
every other day
more on just uh brother stuff um you
know we know there's a line between
uh what we do for a living and and still
being my closest friend and
uh being able to talk family and
everything else but
it'll be interesting i know he joined
last year we ended up
our last game was up in detroit last
year and he was on the sideline for the
first time
but i know he's enjoying it up there i
know
they've done a good job bringing in brad
holmes who i thought did an excellent
job in the draft this year as their
general manager
and dan's a a great leader of men so i
think they're going to be better
uh and they're going to get that program
turned around in terms of your program
uh
what was your goal going into this uh
non-playing season free agency and draft
and how did you attack it
what are you what are you pleased with
coming out of as we're entering memorial
day weekend
rick spillman well it you know it it
presented a lot of challenges uh and for
us especially with where our cap
situation was
uh and being able to get under the cap
because the cap went down
uh but still being able to fill our
needs and we really honed in
in free agency uh this year on the
defensive side of the ball
uh tried to build our defense back up we
were decimated with injuries and just
didn't have
enough talent on that side of the ball
last year so to go out and sign the
tomlinson and the xavier woods and
patrick peterson
mackenzie alexander we needed to get
some veterans
on that side of the ball and you know
i'm counting uh
michael pierce coming that didn't play
for us last year danielle hunter
so i think uh you know and then anthony
barr missed most of the season uh
tearing his peck i think in the second
week against indianapolis
so to get all those guys back hopefully
we'll be a lot better on defense that
was our number one priority
and then filling in some needs that we
were able to do
in the draft especially up on the
offensive line
you know getting a a christian darth all
where we got him in the first
round and davis where we got him in the
third round so
hopefully you know i think everybody's
excited about what they were able to
accomplish this off season both in free
agency and the draft
i know we started otas today and we got
a long way to go till we open up at
cincinnati
but feel pretty good about at least some
of the talent that we're able to uh
bring in and hopefully add to what we
currently have
well at least you don't have a head
coach is probably pushing you every two
seconds to upgrade the defense hold on
i think i'm being told that you it's
probably the exact opposite
no yeah i've heard about it since uh our
last game of the season
yeah it is still he's still out there
yelling about it i'm sure
uh but that's what makes him a great
coach
i bet so uh let me pull on that uh
salary cap string that you you kind of
um
pulled right there um because
you know as i i've been saying over and
over again here on this show that it's
kind of like real estate the salary cap
where
you just assume it's going to go up or
knock on wood your your entire financial
strategy in your own house is based on
the fact that
your house if you're fortunate to own
one or property or anything
the cost is just going to keep going up
and the cap is similar to that and this
year it goes down
when did you learn that and and how did
that how you know what
what plans did you have that were
essentially either confirmed or maybe
sidetracked a little bit by the number
that you got rick spilling
well i think it started uh if you go
back to last year when we did
all of our contracts we didn't know the
cap was going to go down
so all the contracts that we put in
place were assuming that the cap was
going to go up and we
try to say it's going to go up x amount
and try to be conservative on that
number then when it swung down about
30 million the other way on us uh
we had to do a lot a lot of tough
decisions business decisions to get
underneath the cap but also rob
brzezinski did a great job
creating enough room and cap space for
us to be
active in uh free agency and i think
you've seen you know we did a lot of
one-year deals tomlinson was a big sign
for us
uh because i knew going into the draft
it wasn't going to be a real strong
defensive tackle market this year
uh in the draft so we really honed in as
that
being our main signing uh to get a guy
of that caliber in here along with
michael pierce
which would definitely help hopefully
help our run game
or run defense which was very average at
best
last year so but we were able to
accomplish everything we wanted to
accomplish
and still get underneath the cap
although it did require us to make a lot
of difficult decisions that we had to
well and and plus you know you're one of
the few general managers in
the history of the nfl who pays a
quarterback similar to a contract of
like a starting pitcher in baseball
you know and so there's the i guess the
issue
or the the uh the construct that you
have with kirk cousins
and so in that light uh
the drafting of of kalamond here
what do you what do you expect out of
this young man from texas a
m rick you know we went into this
draft and um you know we did not have we
got a couple young guys currently on our
roster jake browning and nate stanley
who are
are battling for the backup positions we
don't have a veteran backup quarterback
so we wanted to add another quarterback
in this draft
to come in and compete and kirk cousins
is our quarterback he's going to be a
quarterback for i know for sure the next
two years
and it was an opportunity to get another
young guy
at a position that our coaches felt that
they could develop
so uh the biggest thing is we don't know
what we have yet
you know because last year we didn't get
to see a nate stanley or jake browning
in preseason so or even during these
otas that we currently are having so
uh very excited to see uh one of these
three young guys
hopefully come up to the top and see
which one
ends up being our our backup quarterback
but all three were excited
about their potential well what did you
like about this kid out of texas a m
that says
let's use a third yeah he was you know
if you watched him
yeah uh you know where he started as a
freshman and where he ended up you just
seen him
progressively get better uh not only
is he a very good athlete that has some
armed talent
uh but also can make plays on his feet
and the one thing that really stuck
out to us as we went through this
process he just got better and better
through the season
i remember the first game i saw was
against florida and he won a very close
game down at texas a m and
we i thought played very well in that
game he goes to north carolina in the
bowl game
beats north carolina who had a lot of
talent on that roster very talented
roster with a lot of guys that
did get drafted into the nfl and then
you seen him take another step down at
the senior bowl
i think ended up being an mvp down at
the senior bowl
played very well in the game and then
our andrew janoko our quarterback coach
went down there and worked him out at
pro day and had an outstanding pro day
workout so
the one thing that really stuck out
about him is he continues to trend
upward where we try to compare these
guys
at any position are they trending up and
down before they
enter into the pre-draft process and he
continued to just check all the boxes
and keep contributing upward
rick spillman here on the rich eisen
show i asked this question of your
colleague brett vich and other general
managers have come on so i'll i'll throw
this one by you do you think we'll ever
see a time in the nfl
where a first-round drafted quarterback
is despite a successful run after being
drafted
uh essentially not given a fifth year
option
and allowed to go elsewhere just because
you don't want to give a quarterback
a big nine-figure deal that that might
actually
uh go with if you will and they just you
just start again
and draft somebody and try and win in
your first iteration of a contract
do you think we'll ever see something
like that in the nfl
rick spielmann uh i don't know that
i mean that's a tough question it
depends on the uh
the individual and the quarterback uh
you know everybody i think would hope
that
brett veach didn't exercise the option
on my home yeah no that's why i kind of
asked him that question rick since he's
kind of on the other side of that
but i feel like you know you've got you
just drafted a quarterback in the third
round that you might hope to have a
long-term future there if not
a longer-term future with with your
current veteran quarterback as well
that's why i'm kind of wondering if you
ever see a
uh a team go and draft somebody in the
first round and instead of giving them
the fifth year option just say you know
what we're just not going to continue to
keep on down this we'll just start again
kind of like college in a way
it depends on what comes out every year
and that is probably the hardest
position to find um to get and how many
you know when you go into a season every
year and you look at your schedule
how many quarterbacks do you actually
face that you know
man we have to really game plan around
this guy or this guy
is unique and there's not a lot of
quarterbacks
up in that upper tier echelon i mean we
play against
a pretty good one in uh in our division
who i think is the best in the league
but when you get a quarterback like that
and you draft one
and he becomes an aaron rodgers or
becomes a tom brady
um you know you hope you're going to
keep them because you know if you got a
guy of that caliber
uh that he's he's always going to give
you a chance to get to the ultimate goal
of winning a super bowl
okay um so i'll ask you one last
question that i'm sure you're
asked by everybody that you know and
love and people come across you and you
definitely don't have the answer to it
but i'm going to ask it anyway
rick spielman um with justin fields now
coming into the bears organization and
you know andy dalton being there those
are two first-year quarterbacks for the
bears there right
the lion's just got jared goff he's he's
in the he's in
his first year there do you think kirk
cousins will be the most tenured nfc
north quarterback to start a game
in the division this year yes or no rick
spielman
what do you think uh i don't know
[Laughter]
that's a that's a hypothetical question
and that's hard for me to
to say uh but you know what's your gun
so let me ask you this are you getting
that question literally everywhere you
you go in minnesota do you think uh do
you think he's gonna play
do you get that question all the time
yeah no if i was on yeah
on your side of the profession i'd give
you a professional opinion
what i do for a living i got to say i
just got to worry about the minnesota
vikings ladies and gentlemen
well done you just got to eat you got
your own house to deal with
right you got your own that's the only
all right very good
but it just it is such a fad like
everybody's talking about it
are you you're getting quite asked that
question all the time though right all
the time
people asking you that yeah people well
yeah some people ask me that and
i just tell them the exact same answer
only thing i can worry about is what we
have here and how we get better from
last year and
and let's see what happens you got your
own purple to deal with how is dalvin
cook
rick how is he uh he looks pretty good
he uh you know just watching him come in
last week and you know
we have mostly all of our players here
right now and just watching him run
around uh
you know i think he's one of the top
running backs uh in the league not only
because of his ability to run
but what he does in a passing game and
how explosive of a playmaker
is but the one thing he doesn't get
enough credit for
is what he does in pass protection and
how smart he is of picking up
blitzes so uh we're very very fortunate
to have a a talent like a dalmacook here
and you stretch that's what our offense
is based off sure based off uh
being able to establish the run and then
and then making uh plays in the passing
game off play action and i think that's
why
kirk cousins had such a great year last
year is because of that
well is that justin jefferson calling
you to remind you to talk about him too
is that who that is
yeah yeah that yeah they're listening
down in the locker room right now you
better get through the rest of
you struck it you struck it rich with
him that's for sure too you've got
you've got a dynamic receiver running
back combination we're not even talking
about feeling
either in that so how
prolific and i know that you've got
again a coach who wants to talk about
running it and getting it back uh
getting in the end zone taking time off
keeping the opposition off the field and
getting the defense back there fresh
i know that's the method there but just
how dynamic do you think this offense
can be
rick well i think we we have a lot of
playmakers on the offensive side of the
ball
uh you know and we were fortunate enough
to get uh
justin where we got him in a draft last
year i don't think anyone can predict
you know on how any of these rookies
were going to perform last year because
of
not having an off season having to
shorten training camp not having
pre-season games and he didn't even
start the first two games then once he
got in the lineup uh he showed what a
dynamic playmaker that he can be
but having uh having that type of talent
uh at the receiver position along with
feeling and
excited about which one of these young
guys are going to surface up is our is
our third receiver but also
i think you're going to see irv smith
really uh excel this year in this draft
and
you know with us having to release kyle
rudolph who's now with the new york
giants
uh to see her smith come into his own
and he made some uh
plays but i i think we have enough
talent
and enough playmakers on the offensive
side of the ball
to give us a chance and as much as uh
people didn't talk about our offense but
we were fourth overall
you know offense last year we were just
you know not as good on defensive
as we have been in the past so to get
all those guys back
on the field to hopefully have upgraded
our offensive line in the off season
and to up the upgrades that we made on
the defensive side of the ball
uh anticipating us uh being able to uh
hopefully stay healthy and have a
successful year all right rick
uh thanks for the time appreciate it if
you are going back in your kanban
meetings know this i'm going on the phil
mickelson eating
plan um and uh you know tb12 being a
fellow michigan man
next year i might i might i might have
to be on your draft board
so just keep an eye on that isn't that
incredible yeah no if you keep bringing
your 40 down
uh you're etching up from the the depths
of their no great
at least on the backboard of our draft
board i appreciate that
there's things to shoot for that's all
i'm saying you just tell you know
tell zimmer i you know i won't fumble
i'll i'll maintain possession that's all
he's looking
for is just and maybe we'll get you some
points that's what i'll do that's all
i i think you should experience playing
corner for coach zimmer and his defense
no i've been around dion long enough who
by the way dion
loves that man he will he he he's like
zimmer's one of his favorite people but
i think i'll just stay where i am i
think i'm good
thank you for the call rick i really
appreciate it thank you okay
thanks appreciate you having me on thank
you thanks for doing that's rick
spellman minnesota vikings gia
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here